if you told me I was gonna get to be a  cat for work what we're gonna take a  load of people and they're gonna pretend  to be cats but if you just say it out  loud it's bonkers but that's where the  most fun happens really I'm observing  all the cats I'm singing and I'm dancing  with the best dancers in the world so I  mean you're interpreting the thing that  Bally's really helped me with for being  a cat has been light on my feet but for  a lot of the other dance styles they  create their own steps they kiss the  music and they just start moving the way  one person comes in and another person  blends their styles together once you've  learned and mastered the rules and  that's when you get to play kind of find  a balance between learning new steps and  new genres it's created a language  between dancers and actors artistically  we feed off of each other put those  things together and I believe that you  have magic  [Music]